well I do think it's partly a human
thing I mean partly anthropologically
frankly biologically there's there's
some hard wiring to avoid death we we
fear you know we have a fright or flight
impulse or response built within ours
hormonal II and neuro chemically in the
leg but but I think it has become more
exaggerated at least during the latter
part of the last century during the last
half of the last century certainly I was
born in 1951 and I and I know my parents
talked about how in the 1930s it began
to become apparent that there were
dramatic miracles happening in medicine
that people would come back from the
hospital after a pneumonia or a serious
urinary infection that should have
killed them but but with the advent of
sulfa and then penicillins and the like
people were were just dramatically
rescued and came back well from the
hospital and then you know cardiac care
got better and people didn't die quite
so quickly from heart attacks and
surgical care got so much better and so
as as the power of medicines fueled by
scientific advances became frankly
dramatic people culturally began to to
learn that the best care possible for
anyone who you loved and is seriously
ill is to put them in the hospital and
frankly even better later in the century
was to have them in the intensive care
unit and then it was the best hospitals
you don't just want any Hospital you
wanted the best Hospital so you know the
American way of dying has has gradually
become a dying in the hospital maybe in
the intensive care unit maybe even
better still at the referral center
hospitals I see you again there's been
no ill intention quite the contrary
but it turns out that nowadays 20% of
Americans die during a hospitalization
that included an ICU admission many
Americans that's a fifth of all American
many Americans are dying tethered to
machines actually having their their
arms restrained so they don't pull out
their breathing tubes on the leg
similarly you know 50% of people die in
hospitals and 30% or so in in nursing
homes this is not the way anybody really
wants it but we've never had sort of a
cultural conversation about what a
healthy last chapter of life looks like
what that would actually look like too
to be taking the best care possible of
one another
professionally and socially in a way
that that is not always seeking to
prolong life and incorporates this
notion that you know dying is going to
happen at some point
you